hello conspiracy theorists and
misinformation specialists i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message it's tuesday november 9th in the
year of 2021 as always uh subscribe to
the channel tap a notification bell if
you see it maybe share our videos and of
course we are now streaming live every
day of the week on rumble.com i believe
we're on the front page of rumble today
uh we're also streaming on the youtube
and at
blazetv.com and there's just a lot going
on in the world people there is a lot
going on so we to do some covid stuff it
just is what it is because whether
the virus at this point is deadly or
deadlier or whatever
more than it was say a month ago they
are just not letting it go and they are
actually exacerbating the situation with
all new regulations and mandates and
everything else and when i say they i
mean our political class our media
the social media companies big tech it's
like they just love this
virus that is in the system this mind
virus which i would say is far worse
than the regular virus so we got four
stories for you today first we're going
to talk about some more travel mandates
and whether now they want to maybe stop
you from traveling within the united
states from state to state if you're not
vaccinated
absolutely bananas then some more
business mandates and it looks like the
biden administration which obviously is
not really the administration he's just
the puppet for something else i just
don't know exactly what but i'm working
on it uh they want now to potentially
ignore
uh
the mandates they want to basically
ignore people that are saying no we
can't have these mandates the courts
that are saying you know we're not going
to allow for this they want to basically
ignore it that's not good you can't do
that the federal government and the
judicial branch these are separate
things right the executive branch
judicial branch they're separate things
they're supposed to push and pull you
can't just ignore laws if you don't like
them but
welcome to biden's america let's go
brandon uh then we found some old video
of fouchy you guys know about this
fouchy guy the guy that gets everything
wrong but keeps smiling and going on all
the sunday shows we found some video of
him it looks like it's from probably
around 1984 1985 during the height of
the aids crisis and you're not going to
believe this he was worried about kids
catching aids
that lived with people with aids and all
sorts of stuff and you'll just see that
this guy has been peddling nonsense
forever
and fear and everything else and then
finally you know there's this big
climate summit it's happening all the
rich people of the world they're all
talking about the climate and trying to
figure out how they can stop mother
nature but most of them are flying there
in private jets and live on the water
and barack obama you remember our
two-term president barack obama
homophobe by the way barack obama who
ran against gay marriage the first time
that he ran for president well
he said that you know he could maybe
give up some stuff in the name of
climate change of course he did just buy
i think an 11 million dollar house on
martha's vineyard on the water which if
you thought that the sea levels are
rising maybe you'd want to live inland
but you know we'll talk about that
all right let's uh let's get right to it
uh so first off jen saki who you know is
the white house press secretary she got
kovid what about seven eight nine days
ago or so has not been seen since now of
course she was vaccinated so it might
lead you to believe that the vaccines
aren't working exactly as they were
promised but in any event she is out of
the way right now and there is a backup
press secretary her name is karine
jean-pierre
and she was given the press a conference
yesterday and she said some really
strange things when it comes to domestic
travel your ability to visit friends and
relatives throughout the country we've
got video tape
thank you the u.s is now accepting fully
vaccinated travelers from countries that
were previously restricted during the
pandemic
given how rapidly the delta variant
spread here within the united states
over the summer why are still no vaccine
or testing requirements for domestic
travel so you know we say this all the
time everything's on the table we just
don't have any announcement to to
preview right now on this um so i don't
have anything more to share on the
domestic travel
everything's on the table related to
domestic travel sure maybe we won't let
you get on planes anymore maybe we won't
let you hop in your car and go from
california to vegas or new york to
jersey or dare drive across the country
even though a lot of people have been
vaccinated and i thought these vaccines
were supposed to work and everything
else everything is on the table and when
i played that clip this morning for my
guys i thought everything's on the table
didn't we play a clip yesterday where
nothing was off the table what clip was
that and yeah it's a clip we showed you
yesterday surgeon general
the surgeon general he's talking about
how nothing's off the table when it
comes to small businesses dr murthy if
the law survives legal challenges will
the administration be extending the
mandate to smaller employers with fewer
than 100 employers employees
well martha certainly nothing is off the
table at this moment but the focus right
now is on implementing
the current rule that osha put out
okay so just to be clear this table has
got a lot going on because everything is
on the table when it comes to how they
can stop us from traveling which i think
would be unconstitutional and nothing is
off the table when it comes to how they
could control how they could control our
businesses and i do want to remind you
guys once again i will not be forcibly
injecting you with anything and we're
having jersey mike's for lunch so put
your order in while i'm doing the show
would you um these people are completely
ridiculous nothing's off the table
everything's on the table
they just want more and more
control it's absolutely crazy notice i
say this all the time but notice they
never give you numbers
you know they never give you well okay
how many people hopped on planes say
from los angeles and flew to phoenix and
in the course of that plane ride got
people sick on the plane and then caused
an outbreak of covid in phoenix or vice
versa and then those people from phoenix
took a drive to tempe arizona and then
got people sick there they never give
numbers related to any of this because
nothing
that you're hearing about kovid at this
point has anything to do with science it
has everything to do with control that
really is it at this point which is why
they don't give you numbers it's why
fauci always says well when things
change we'll have to see and the
winter's coming and manageable levels
they never tell you the number two weeks
to flatten the curve what happened to
that
man it's like it's like broken record
stuff because these people are just
gonna take and take and take until we
just say sorry you cannot take anymore
you can't you can't take anymore i'm
going to travel where i want to travel
i'm going to work with who i want to
work with i'm going to go where i want
to go and then what are you going to do
i mean are you going to literally shoot
me in the name of health are you going
to arrest me in the name of health like
is that really where we're at but i
think we just have to
start ignoring these people
and we've got more things coming up in
just a second that we're going to have
to ignore out of them because they're
just they're just on the march and
you know i've had jordan peterson on the
show this morning we're gonna play it a
little bit later and we we get into this
that it's just
like a series of people who are sort of
not representing themselves they're
representing organizations so they
represent the cdc or they represent the
government or they represent a
corporation and what that does is it
creates a situation where no one
represents the individual anymore so
everyone has to protect their ass at all
times or protect something that's kind
of above them some structure or business
or governmental organization that's
above them and no one represents just
the decent guy who's trying to live
their life and make some choices for
themselves that's what we gotta get back
to here because these guys are gonna
keep coming and i've got plenty more on
that but before i get to that
you know we've been telling you about
chamonix and geniusel plant stem cell
therapy around here for a couple weeks
now and when i look back at my first
prageru video i was stressed at the time
i wasn't sleeping well i could see big
bags under my eyes they're gone now but
no more just use jen you sell by shamany
all over your face and under your eyes
fine lines forehead wrinkles dark bags
uh puffiness under your eyes gone right
before your eyes and best of all
guaranteed results in as little as 12
hours where you get your money back it's
that simple now get this genusell has
now sold over a million products that's
a million products lots of companies
have tried to duplicate them and all
they do is fail it's for both men and
women even my assistant helen loves
their crystallis microdermabrasion
treatment and tells me it makes her skin
feel unbelievably clean and smooth as a
matter of fact helen is in the live chat
right now and helen i have to say you've
been looking very bright and alive
lately so maybe you want to post a
picture in the chat right now that
people can see
once people try genusell products they
fall in love and buy them again and
again from now until thanksgiving you
can see the difference yourself with
sixty percent off january cell packages
sixty percent just go to love
lovegeniacell.com
dave that's love g-e-n-u-c-e-l
dot com slash dave to get 60 off
packages order now and express shipping
is free that's
lovegenyasel.com dave and now back to me
okay so i we separated these two stories
but in many ways you're gonna see the
connection points here because it's just
more and more nonsense by an out of
control government that has now decided
that the very laws that we live by
the constitution no longer applies to
them that's what they think now of
course we did have two sham impeachments
of orange man uh but they think these
people think that uh they don't have to
listen to the constitution they don't
have to listen to laws or anything else
uh so here is karine jean-pierre again
she is the temporary i suppose
replacement for jen saki who is out
because of covet even though she was
vaccinated
basically saying that uh we're gonna go
ahead and keep forcing businesses to
vaccinate people regardless of whether
it's legal or not or what the courts say
we know the vaccine requirements work
and we're going to continue to push that
you know we're going to make sure that
we get as many people vaccinated
it is it is uh it is so important to get
this pandemic behind us and to get the
economy going and so that's i mean
that's going to continue to be our
message is to to tell anyone that we're
working with whether it's a democrat or
republican that this is how we have to
move forward to make sure that we get
out of the situation that we're in to
get out this pandemic again we still
have 1300 people a day approximately
1300 people a day dying of cobit that is
that we should not that should not be
the number that we're looking at um and
we believe
that in order to get this pandemic
behind us we get we need to get more
people vaccinated and this is a way uh
to do that and we see vaccination
requirements work uh and and also it's
important to keep people safe in their
workplace uh that should be you know
should be mission critical in making
sure that that happens uh and so we're
gonna you know we feel confident about
the the legal component of this
the department of labor have the has the
authority uh to move forward uh in
making sure that they keep the workplace
safe uh and so uh yeah we have to make
sure that we get this pandemic behind us
the department of labor has the
authority no they don't like these
people are just terrible i have to say
she's slightly more likable than saki
saki is just absolutely terrible this
lady she's a little bit better i would
suppose in the likability but again
she's just a [ __ ] artist no notice
she never said anything about the
constitution she never said anything
about the bill of rights she never said
anything about individual rights or just
your decision to make a medical uh
decision for yourself they just don't
care now she did say 1300 people a day
okay so let me just assume for a second
i'll go out on the assumption and say
she's not flat out lying about that
let's just say 1300 people are dying a
day now we have about 340 million or so
people in america people die of all
sorts of things can we get a number
maybe on how many people die of uh
getting hit by a car give me give me
something on how many people die of
different things like should we not
allow people in cars like what what are
we really talking about also could i get
some numbers like related to
co-morbidity as on those people were
they all 87 years old and seriously fat
and had other diseases like we should
know about some of the stuff but they
don't care what she really really wants
is the government the federal government
to just ram through decisions
and not care what the courts say so one
of the courts decided that this is not
constitutional you can't just force
companies to do that again really just
putting aside partisan stuff putting
aside everything really think how
bananas it would be if after lunch where
as i already said we're having jersey
mics it's not the healthiest lunch but i
was letting you guys have it today
if i grabbed one of these people and
took them to cvs and forced a stranger
to inject them with something so that
they could continue to work for me would
that be sensible i don't think that
would be sensible we've got some
information here 3
700 people die from car wrecks every day
that's according to the association for
safe international road travel one of my
favorite organizations 3 700 people die
a day should we get the roads the cars
off the roads i mean what what are we
really
really talking about here they just want
more power and and now we've got a scary
video if you didn't think that was kind
of scary and it is kind of scary the
idea that the federal government thinks
it can just run over the courts that's
kind of scary in one way but they talk
in such a way that makes it sound like
they're actually doing something legit
even though it's not you get my point
but if you thought that was sort of
scary or like a little weird or whatever
she's got nice hair so maybe she's not
so bad um here's the pfizer ceo his
name's albert borla this video just
broke in the last like 20 minutes before
we started
talking about misinformation related to
covid and what we should do
with the people who share
misinformation
but there is a very small part
of professionals which they circulate on
purpose misinformation so that they will
mislead
those that they have concerns
those people are criminals they're not
dead people they're criminals because
they literally cost
millions of lives and then should be
treated as criminals as well
those who have done that
they should be treated as criminals
they've cost millions of lives
misinformation related to covet has cost
millions lives we have no evidence that
that's true but if you want to talk
about misinformation related to covert
we should talk about anthony fauci we
should talk about him lying under oath
to congress about mrnas we should talk
about how he told his friends that they
could go on vacation and not worry about
masks because you touch your face more
with masks we should talk about two
weeks to flatten the curve have they
lied about that i mean all of the stuff
lockdowns work there's no evidence that
lockdowns work like misinformation
you're right man and if you want to
criminalize that stuff and by the way
i'm pretty sure that the ceo of pfizer
doesn't get to decide who is a criminal
and what should happen to criminals at
least not yet even though pfizer does
sponsor all of our mainstream media you
may remember we played that compilation
a couple weeks ago now i was thinking uh
there there was a word as i was watching
that guys that uh i wanted to say to uh
that fellow there that ceo of pfizer but
i can't say it because if i say it we
get demonetized so i just want to i'm
just going to read my notes here
for just a second and uh
okay i think
did we we did it we made the point okay
next up speaking of misinformation so
fouchy
oh tony tony the infallible fouchy this
guy you know it's like i've said many
times i really don't want to impugn him
his motives sometimes i'm a little
sarcastic when talking about him i would
like to believe
that the head of nih the guy that's been
in charge of this whole thing really has
good intentions and really didn't
intentionally fund the research that led
to the gain of function and then
potentially was leaked from the lab
either intentionally or not like i i'd
like to believe that this guy wants to
help people but i think there's a lot of
evidence at this point that anthony
fauci who is again the highest paid
person in the federal government makes
over 400 grand a year it's a pretty
decent salary right on top of the fact
that i can only imagine what his
investment portfolio looks like related
to all of these companies and everything
else but i know we're not allowed to
talk about that sort of thing um he has
gotten so many things wrong all
throughout um he's been glib and
dismissive uh if you question him he
basically there was that great video a
couple months back i am the science
basically he thinks he's palpatine i
mean the guy the guy is just terrible
but i saw a video this morning that i
think perfectly illustrates the sort of
fear-mongering that this guy has been
doing now
everyone remembers the aids crisis
in the early to mid 80s in new york city
i mean it was of course all over the
world but sort of ground zero of it was
the 80s in new york city and there was a
lot of misinformation there was a lot of
worry about how it was spreading usually
it was spread through unsafe sex
and through needles like drug users and
needles that was pretty much it but i
want you to listen to fouchy here again
i think this is 1984 1985 or so we got
this from uh was this from grabbing
media i think so no this is uh we'll get
we'll source it properly in just a sec
um but listen to what he's saying and
just sort of
decide for yourself does this sound very
very oddly almost eerily similar to
everything we're hearing these days
starting to see as we're seeing
virtually as the months go by other
groups that can be involved and seeing
it in children is really quite
disturbing let me say other close
contact give me some examples well for
example if if the close contact of a
child is a household contact perhaps
there will be a certain number of cases
of individual who are just living with
and in close contact with someone with
aids or risk of aids who does not
necessarily have to have uh intimate
sexual contact or share a needle but
just the ordinary close contact that one
sees in normal interpersonal
relationships
okay so as you saw in the video there
that was originally from abc news but
did you catch what he just said right
there at the height of this thing that
he basically said oh a kid that's living
with someone with aids could potentially
get aids from that person without having
sexual contact obviously not trading a
needle with someone now there's no
evidence for that there never was
evidence for that okay but he's using
the same sort of fear tactics what are
these tactics well the tactics are you
take a whole bunch of people who aren't
scientists right who you know are just
trying to live their lives figure out
what's what and then the expert class
comes in and goes oh there's a there's a
problem and we know there's a problem
right i'm not saying that the aids
crisis didn't exist i'm not saying that
covid as a virus
doesn't exist to this day but then they
start saying things that make everyone
crazy and fearful so he starts saying
well you know you might have a person
who lives in a house with a child and if
that person had aids there might be some
way of spreading aids to that person
which is the exact same thing he's doing
now he's telling you that we have to
vaccinate children so that the children
don't infect the vaccinated adults
none of it makes sense we have
outsourced our decision making we have
outsourced our logic and our thinking to
people who
we have the video proof who get
everything wrong and not everything
wrong over just a couple months
everything wrong now dating back to you
know 30 40 years ago it's absolutely
crazy but just quickly jumping back for
just a second to that video of the the
pfizer ceo i mean think how dangerous
what he is saying he's just a drug
company ceo i thought we were supposed
to be against giant corporate
conglomerates and we should be a little
wary of what they want to inject us in
with and you know
too many of us are on pills and all
sorts of things like we should be a
little wary of these people who are at
record profits who are sponsoring all
the news that covers them and here
you've got this ridiculous
person
blaming
deaths
blaming deaths on misinformation and
what he means by misinformation is not
he doesn't mean misinformation like
abject lies he means people who question
what pfizer is doing
so like what are you gonna do man you're
gonna jail me you're gonna jail me for
asking questions for saying you're not a
good dude and i don't know who that
interviewer was but the interviewer you
know oh yeah yeah we got to deal with
those people they're they're criminals
man what a collection of ridiculous
human beings we are dealing with on a
daily basis
but at least around here at the reuben
report we're having jersey mike's for
lunch okay so everything's gonna be okay
getting the classic italian little spicy
mustard some jalapenos it's gonna be
just fine
all right let's move on to the fourth
story today there is this big climate
conference right now and you guys get it
you get the hypocrisy with these people
they fly in their private jets trust me
these people don't give a f
poop about the environment what they
like is power
they as they slowly shift us out of
covid the next thing that they will try
to lock us down for
is the environment and they'll tell you
not to drive your car so much while they
fly in private jets and they'll tell you
to eat bugs while they eat wagyu steak
in elysium etc etc
well two-term president barack obama he
showed up to this thing and he gave a
little talk and if uh if you want to
watch the definition of hypocrisy take a
look
with a higher per capita carbon
footprint does have to do more than
a country like mali or bangladesh
it's also why we need to make sure the
people most affected by the transition
to clean energy
aren't the ones bearing most of the cost
they don't have any margin for error
i can afford to give up a lot
of my current lifestyle to benefit the
planet because i'll still have a lot
left over a lot of folks don't have that
cushion
so that means that any climate plan
worth of salt has to take
these inequities into account whether
it's through subsidies
to poor people to ease the transition to
clean energy whether it's technology
transfers that help poor countries meet
their development goals by leapfrogging
dirty fuels we have to pay attention to
those
embedded inequities
and the politics that surrounds them
and that's not easy
do you guys see how this stuff is just
all connected like this is what build
back better is this is what the sort of
globalist
order is all about we create crises and
then we lecture you you the people who
will have to get used to less but we
certainly will not and the reason i said
that this is an uh an exercise in
hypocrisy basically listening to him is
he said that he can afford to give up a
lot
he can afford to give up a lot well i
was thinking well what has barack obama
given up i think we've got an image
we've got an image that's barack obama's
new house that's an
11.75 million dollar house right by the
water
it's very very close to the water i hope
it's on stilts that's in martha's
vineyard massachusetts where it's
surrounded by the elite and the rich and
all of the people who have all of the
stuff that you do not if i'm not
mistaken barack obama also has a house
in palm springs which is the middle of
the desert
um here in you know outside of los
angeles where there's nothing there and
they've had to pump tons and tons of
water there to just make sure that the
rich people can have their nice pools
and everything else i'm not against rich
people number one i'm not against rich
people having nice things i'm not
against pools i'm not against mansions
you can have all of those things but try
not to be such a hypocrite about it if
barack obama really feared
that the water was rising at such an
alarming rate that we're gonna have to
figure out how to help other countries
uh leapfrog their way so that they don't
have to deal with dirty energy like we
did because we're very guilty and white
supremacist blah blah blah
if he really believed any of this was
true he would not can we get that house
again look at that how many rooms is
that thing that is a lot of rooms in
that thing they got rooms i guarantee
you he's got a gym i guarantee he's got
a sauna and a steam room and again i
don't begrudge him any of these things i
do wonder how he got millions and
millions of dollars i mean i know
netflix gave him a ton of money to
promote propaganda on netflix but like
would you be living right by the water
you know we just came back from miami
and in miami you've got all of these
literally these 30 40 50 70 million
dollar houses all on the water
right and they're telling us the sea
level's rising get why are all the rich
people still moving to the water are
they stupid
or
could it possibly be
that all of this is really about control
and they're trying to usher in a whole
bunch of polities that policies that
will enshrine that they always kind of
stay in power and you eat bugs
bug mush with a little salt it's
delicious
guys part one oh no the full episode uh
my full interview with rumble ceo chris
pavlovsky is up right now and we talk
about the merger with locals what we're
doing why we're doing it how we're
operating these businesses and as a
matter of fact if you go to
reubenreport.locals.com
it's the pin post right now and chris
will be in the comment section all day
so if you have any questions related to
our policies related to anything
regarding the merger how rumble is
operating our infrastructure why we did
the deal whatever you want we really are
trying to do this different differently
than the big boys okay we're trying to
do it differently than youtube and
google and everybody else so chris will
be in the comment section all day today
responding to comments he's already been
doing it all day and he'll continue it
throughout the day so do check that out
and then as i said i interviewed jordan
peterson this morning it's about an hour
and about an hour and a half and we try
to churn and
crunch through a lot of this stuff and
by the way it's a lot about the
environment it's a lot about the
overreaction to covid it's about god and
religion and the whole thing like we did
just sort of a little bit of everything
we could have gone for three days
without stopping uh but it's about an
hour and a half i think you'll enjoy it
and of course uh it will be up first at
reubenreport.locals.com
and then it'll be on uh youtube and
rumble and all that good stuff uh all
right that's it do we have any comments
any comments you want to share with me
today we've got something you'll give me
uh let's see what the people were saying
during the show anyway i think you got
the theme of the show today was just
like we you know it's like we got to
make fun of these people we got to
realize
that they're not doing this for us like
they're not putting you in masks
because they like you they're not trying
to save you you can save yourself that's
it man that really is it all right a
couple comments before we uh shut down
here uh nuclear patrick says could obama
give up race-baiting to help stop kovid
it would be like giving up something for
lent yeah you know it's really
unfortunate and i've said it before i
voted for obama twice i really do
regret that you know it's not like i got
any great love for mccain or uh or
romney but like you know we'd be in a
much different situation obama says all
the right things while doing the wrong
things you you cannot
you you cannot if you tell believe that
the sea levels are rising be buying a
basically a 12 million dollar house on
the water while he'll lecture us about
what we have to do it's just absolutely
crazy
crazy peter says sometimes real life
looks like parody indeed it does we're
just in a parody we're just in
like a non-stop parody here pretty much
it's just every you wake up and you go
what stupid oh they're not going to let
us travel across state lines okay that's
one thing oh they're going to not pay
attention to the laws that are being
passed oh they're going to want more of
your money oh they want more of your
stuff oh they want to lock you in the
basement oh they want to fish you feed
your fish heads once a week okay fine uh
and a little more info this is from
chris obama's house has seven bedrooms
and nine bathrooms it's a cool seven
thousand square feet again i don't
begrudge people
from doing whatever it is they want to
do with their money i don't like class
warfare i don't like the idea of saying
oh those people have that so they must
be destroyed but that's exactly what
they're doing they're doing it they're
pretending that it's the corporations
that are evil that and i'm not even
defending the corporation they're just
ugh you get it you get it all right
do we all we feel good about this we
feel like we did a show here who wants
jersey mike's
i got two thumbs up alright guys see you
tomorrow